today's episode is brought to you by
grey block pizza
if you've wanted that that feeling in
your mouth that's warm and cheesy and
meaty
and crusty well you don't have to do
something
unnatural anymore you can go to a
wonderful place called
grey block pizza in los angeles 1811
pico boulevard on the way to the beach
gray block
get that hitter baby today's guest is a
man
and he's really one of a kind and
and very unique
he is an actor he's a podcaster
he is a part of the bad friends podcast
and host of whiskey ginger he's a
comedy anne and he's my friend mr andrew
[Music]
santino
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
he's got really nice smooth skin it's
like wax paper
yeah he's almost not real at some point
i don't know if
we might find out that he's not real
yeah but he's a sweet sweet boy
oh at some point the jumanji game is
gonna end somewhere and he's gonna
disappear he's just gonna
so you you're y'all's new show is called
bad friends bad friends yeah
and who is worst friends you and bobby
or me and um
what's it called pirates booty himself
bernie shout out albanian vernon
yeah i think i think you guys are
working barnyard barnyard yeah
barn door schluben is probably uh you
guys are worse friends
no no no one's me and bobby are friends
i'll ask you this how about this bobby
and i yeah are friends because we get
mad at each other all the time
okay like are you and brendan friends
because you you you bicker a lot do you
bicker a lot and it makes you closer or
no
well that's a good question i mean yeah
the reason the show even started was
because we were ripping on each other
yeah right okay so with us it started
because we undeniably
have opposing lifestyles so we would we
would
tease each other and get mad at each
other for i oh i hated that he played
video games until four in the morning oh
yeah
he thinks he thinks sports are are for
losers yeah we're polar opposites
i like that stuff he likes that stuff
and we make fun of each other for but
it just it works like the way that you
and barnard [ __ ] on each other
yeah it's beautiful because i know half
of it's real
and half of it's all love yeah but it's
you know there's a bat there's a balance
to all
yeah it's that it's that heartfelt dung
really a lot of it
you know it's like hey here's a turd but
man i you know i put a valentine at the
end it looks nice i wrapped it up guys
yeah i wrapped this piece of [ __ ] for
you but but you mean a lot to me
yeah that's kind of how it is man you
look good you feel good
i feel okay man i'm going to nashville
to look around over there
i know we talked huh are you excited
i looked at houses online when i texted
you when you said you were looking at
nashville i looked on houses online just
to see what they're like over there
it's so funny to think that like uh
could you get something nice there
you can you can but not not like i
thought it would be
right because nashville is popular dude
yeah that's not that's this isn't like a
you know when somebody's like i'm moving
to cincinnati you're like all right
you're going to buy the whole town and
you could buy
you could buy cincinnati yeah but you go
to nashville it's
still like it is out here it's a little
expensive in the sense of like
you know you're gonna get your money's
worth but it's pricey yeah because it's
desirable
tennessee is great there's no state
income tax yeah right it's also
nashville is
a hub for music and culture and art
anytime you get that and
you're going to have people going there
from places like illinois where i'm from
there's too expensive to live the taxes
are as much as they are
my parents pay almost what i pay no way
yeah in taxes for their house
and your parents are still married yeah
damn
yeah but i mean legally legally right
because when my dad's retired you know
do they sleep in the same bedroom still
no yes and no my dad stays up late at
night
yeah so he doesn't go you know that's
the move when you're
when you're when it gets to that age
when it's the final 20
yeah and it's that final 20 years when
that last quarter
yeah when that last lap starts the big
move is to stay in front of the tv as
long as you can
once the spouse goes to bed because then
they go to bed then you go oh i felt i
fell asleep i didn't know i just
i didn't know you went up last night i
fell asleep yeah he loves the couch
sometimes he sleeps in the guest room
sometimes because he says he didn't if
he goes i had a cough or i didn't feel
good separation i don't like sleeping in
the same bed
oh do you like sleeping the same bed as
a lady no no i'm like sitting in the
same apartment
i know i want a shared room that's why i
want to get a big enough house where my
wife can be on one side i can be on the
other
i have a couple friends like that yeah
they're just big enough homes where they
split
yeah i won't have a schedule in the
kitchen you know we'll meet here at noon
yeah you know but i can be in my wing
you're in your wing we'll link up for
breakfast
yeah then we continue on how great is
that that's beautiful man
i don't like sleeping in the same bed
i'm dead serious i don't i don't i want
i want my whole space i get too hot i
get anxious i flip around do you wake up
at night or no
yeah i'm up all night long yeah you seem
like somebody that was oh my
god i wake up i go to the bathroom i go
to bed i wake up i go i go write
something down
i watch tv i i can't sleep through the
night
write something down yeah what is this
are you in like
are you on a ship and there's something
murder mysteries
week to week and if i think of the blood
was on his shoe and then i'll write it
down
no if i get a thought that i can't i
need like yeah you gotta write it down
you put it in your phone don't you put
stuff in your phone like that yeah let
me i'll read a couple yeah read
something that you throw down in your
phone recently
let me see what what a comic's condition
but of mine's about gays and a lot of
mine's racial stuff too oh same
oh blind puzzle making i thought would
be good if they had a game show where it
was blind people making puzzles you know
oh i love that
uh this says why do adults like to get
spanked why do adults like to get
spanked during sex
it's gross it's indicative of childhood
trauma
it's very strange like knock it out
knock that trump yeah you want to spank
the trauma right out of me yeah
that's where the term daddy bothers me
when i have a son
i'll i'll hit him in the face if he
calls me daddy yeah i'm papa
or pop or dad yeah daddy is gross daddy
yuck oh yeah daddy's too much it's gross
father
father father's nice yes father yes boy
yes yeah go fetch your pal yeah go fetch
your pale boy
um dude i get a text i get a dm from
this company that i've never answered
but for the past
seven months they've hit me up and they
say who's your jeweler
who do you use as a jeweler they're a
jewelry company
i don't ever wear jewelry i i i don't
even wear a wedding ring i don't like
jewelry
i don't like stuff and they hit me up
every other week they erase their dm and
they send it again
who's your jeweler i think i might need
to go get some jewelry you think i'm
trying to take a
chain oh i could see you in a chain i
could see you in a wrist
in a wrist chain tennis bracelet
but i want it on my ankle like a girl i
want like a girl on spring break dude
i want one above each knee
yeah i want to that i want savage yeah
right above your knee wrapped around
that's that's dope
would that be fun if you had twenty
thousand dollars on each leg i would
love that
my knees are blinged out dude that's so
wild man to think that
like i wonder like yeah what jewelry is
gonna be like in the future like if we
like if people are gonna start to get
more stuff like installed into their
bodies yeah bro have you seen in their
teeth
will it all be virtual i mean i've seen
those johnny dang have you seen that guy
no no i mean in their teeth
people put diamonds in their tooth yes
simon rex has one that's
wild they like they physically put it
into your tooth yeah
they used to put it on your tooth now
they can drill a hole and put a diamond
in your tube get in there there's johnny
dang right there yeah
every rapper sings about johnny dang yep
and he's that vietnamese gateway to the
uh
gateway to the ice game yeah he's like
what you need more ice on you you don't
have no mouth
you don't have enough look at how much
ice he's holding he's iced out yeah
these are all diamond everything for you
he's so tiny too oh yeah look at him and
you know they they grow him for the show
when they do when they do recordings oh
he's a little boba drink yeah
they stretch him out he could sip right
out of his little ass look at him with
that girl in that vice article up there
he could
he could fit inside of her tits oh he's
a nice little sliver of a man oh
beautiful look at the look in his eyes
to the excitement he's so happy about
life yeah he feels good about life
yeah um these guys have beautiful
stories i'm always impressed by this
kind of stuff
oh yeah they make it from zero you know
like builds his own empire we're talking
zero like dude i remember when i was on
when i went on semester at sea so it was
like a school you know yeah
like a campus on a cruise ship kind of
yeah yeah so i remember we were coming
into port in the morning we would get
into like the different port cities
because you kind of go to different
cities around the globe right
so we get into port city i remember
being up in the morning was the biggest
thing if you could be up at like 5 a.m
as you come into the port of a new
country you've never been to right
pretty crazy yeah that's wild
and i remember getting into vietnam and
like
passing fishing boats like in a i mean
we're in like a cruise ship
right you know and passing fishing boats
like little guy
hat you know like a mouthful of melon
like he would fill his mouth with melon
in the morning then just only swallow a
little bit throughout the day like that
was his lunch yeah
kind of like one of those little drip
bottles for a hamster but built into him
and then uh and he would just be out
there just fishing man and
a cruise ship it was almost like just
two time zones
passing each other like oh yeah just and
it would just be so bizarre like the
wake of this cruise ship just going in
rocking his boat yeah
lifting these little bitty skiffs that
they were out there and that's his
entire living
yeah he's sitting out there doing
fishing in the morning and you guys
meanwhile are showing up
just to party been yeah up all night
partying
bootleg cocaine then we bought in some
country that we made how bad is bootleg
cocaine oh
some guy was making cocaine i remember
was it good here's what i would say it
didn't damage you
yeah it wasn't gonna hurt you yeah so
you could do as much as you wanted you
weren't gonna get high but you weren't
gonna
you weren't gonna get hurt your heart
wasn't gonna stop yeah yeah
see that's the opposite with like bad
weed bad weed makes you feel sick
right and you get a headache and your
stomach kind of turns and you feel gross
it's like bad wheat is bad bad coke is
just not real
yeah it's just yeah that's what it was
not real coke but somebody made it man
this guy had this whole little deal
going on
um and he was making it man so that was
cool just to get some it was even if it
didn't work just right
just knowing you got it isn't that half
of the hunt half of the fun was getting
getting drugs and then when you get
drugs you do them and you're like this
is great but
getting the drugs was really fun yeah
because the people you would get in
trouble with
dude i've told this story before but i
used to do drugs with this guy whose
parents were both deaf
oh wow yeah and his dad would come in
the room sometimes we'd be high as [ __ ]
david was his name or not danny
what was his real what was his name his
name was this is so i don't remember i'm
being serious we had a deaf fellow named
david
oh you oh it wasn't his parents i don't
even know this kid i don't remember his
name i just remember he had deaf parents
and i really
well death runs in the is that him is
that deaf david oh i don't know this guy
does have an earpiece in let's hear what
he had to say
death runs in the in the david family
you go
cheeto [ __ ] i've got a question for
you
what drug wouldn't you take i think mine
is probably [ __ ]
heroin because you know no [ __ ]
needles what's up
so what do you think gang dude
a big guy like that could handle a
little bit he could enter some wind yeah
you know a little vein the size of those
baseball mid hands he's oh you could
shoot right into that middle finger
though
you know what i'm saying he said what
drug wouldn't i take yeah i mean
i he did say but that's the thing about
the mistake of heroin he thinks you just
have to shoot it you don't have to just
shoot it
you could snort it you can smoke it so
like needles scare him you could snort
and smoke heroin that's not
i don't think i would want to do heroin
but i think the drug i really wouldn't
take
um i don't think i i don't think i will
i don't think i'll ever do ayahuasca i
know people
i don't know i don't really want it i
don't know any people having a
religious experience on it i don't know
if i really i've done dmt
once and that was fun but i don't know
i don't really want to do drugs anymore
i barely smoke pot
anymore damn i just like drinking you
sound like a damn grandparent you don't
want to do drugs anymore i don't want to
do drugs anymore man
i think i did drugs that i need to do i
think i've done enough drugs that i
needed to do
but what about i could see you i did
mushrooms this weekend i did mushrooms
this weekend okay now we're getting
somewhere but they're chocolate
mushrooms and you take a little bit
now do you feel anything or not yeah you
feel a little fun it's a little funny
dude you take them with the misses
some buds some people came over i had
people it was some it was two of my
friends birthdays and we threw a little
like happy birthday and then we
projected a movie on the
garage wall outside i got a projector
yeah and we watched the sand lot
probably one of the best movies of all
time does the wife drug or not
no no drugs no drugs just drinking she
doesn't she never did drugs never tried
never really got into him
wow she's not opposed to them but i i've
also just grown weary of doing dru i
don't want to do
i did drugs when i was young as much as
i could and then now i'm like
what is it do you feel like you the body
can't handle it do you feel like it's
not
that's that's the first step is it yeah
i just i can't my
your body is you ruined two days now
yeah i used to be able to do drugs and
function
go to work yeah i should do drugs at
work yeah yeah yeah think about that
half the people that are at work all
right or
on drugs yeah all the chefs at a kitchen
bro
yeah if your order comes out quick
that's drugs that's drugs
yeah people are like oh man this this
restaurant is great dude he's just he's
amped the [ __ ] up that's drugs
eggs hash browns eggs eggs i was i just
i just never i just got to a point
i think where i did a lot of drugs when
i was young and then now all i like to
do was
smoke some weed and drink but even wheat
has taken a back seat in my life i don't
know why i just i just don't
and do you ever remember i remember
getting so high at this girl's house one
time when i was young that i couldn't
even
i remember telling some girl like i
remember being stuck in this bedroom
like laying on my back on this
bed or couch and i was so high like
everybody else had gotten high and going
to do something fun
right right and i was like all right i'm
coming and as i'm getting up to leave
out of the door
i can't i couldn't get out of my body i
couldn't my body was stuck
in there yeah and so i'm like laying
there and some girl came back in the
room to get something right
and i remember just being like hey hey
hey you know
get me you know get me and i remember
this girl
looking at me and i think she thought i
was trying to hit on her or something i
might have been you know because even
half and half yeah [ __ ] even though even
though i'm down for the count you know
i can't move but i'll [ __ ] yeah halfway
through a 10 count i'll still get my
dick up you know
even at six i'll [ __ ] say come [ __ ]
you know
but um but i remember this girl just
looking at me
and i remember speaking but i couldn't i
it was the only scent
like skill i had left was to speak to
get it out yeah like
get me get me you know and they laugh
man and i just remember being trapped
there literally
felt like i was loitering in my own body
that wouldn't move
yeah like just wandering around the
hallways of my body
trespassing yeah trust me i wanted to
call the cops on yourself
get out of my body yeah i had i i got so
high one time at a college party
and i went in this girl's room uh to
just get away from people because i was
getting i was like my heart was jumping
i was feeling really [ __ ] up and i was
like having a panic attack that i'm like
i'm too drunk i'm too [ __ ] high i'm
on a few things i'm feeling real [ __ ]
up
so i go i go oh dude i hate it i go and
sit down in her bed
and i curled up and i woke up to her and
her roommate
screaming at me like get the [ __ ] out
get the [ __ ] out you [ __ ] pieces
i was like not too lazy i knew
something's too high i had like to drive
tears at this point because i cried and
prayed to god ten times don't don't
don't let me die like this in this
[ __ ]
this girl's one bedroom one bath i don't
i just don't want to die in a small
place
yeah i want to die in a big house it
doesn't have to be mine yeah but if i'm
going to die of drugs i want to die in a
big house
oh wow you know dining in a small place
is sad yeah
if you're right there they find you
right away they walk in they know you're
right there there's no
there's no investigation there's no
mystery there's no allure right there's
no hearing their heels
uh walk on the on the nice floors as
they look for you
yeah no where could he be is he in here
no no
no not in there upstairs yeah
yeah no i didn't want to die i didn't
want to die like that i did that's what
college was college was bad for me like
that
i got myself in bad situations in
college with drugs that's probably why i
don't want to do them anymore
just just nights of like i remember
sitting watching my buddy and were you
doing cocaine or drugs
just every i did anything that came my
way i would take all sorts of fun [ __ ]
as long as other people were doing it
i'll take it i'd throw a pill in my
throat i didn't really i was like okay
if other people were doing it i was down
to have fun with if we were
all doing it but i remember one night my
buddy was playing he played
acoustic guitar and he was he was so
high on cocaine
that he was playing so much and his you
know he's doing that like coke mouse and
he doesn't even realize he's cutting his
finger his cuticles are bleeding because
he's playing so hard
but i didn't want to stop him because
the song was so good i just let him ride
it out
you know what i mean i have like a
musical bible yeah you're only going to
get dave matthews crash into me so many
times live
so i was like let that [ __ ] play
yeah i've seen some people do some nasty
[ __ ] on drugs
it turns you off as you get older yeah
the older you get and you see people get
real [ __ ] up
you go ugh that's not cool anymore it
looks sad now
yeah what is it there's something about
it that gets
well when you're younger it's more like
you have time to kill for sure totally
so it's like oh if i burn two days doing
this or
whatever yeah and your body can recover
quicker yeah
and you have no your responsibilities
are less you have nobody to answer to
right like oh if i just lay in my bed
for a day and a half it's going to be
chill
right it'll be it'll be great actually
yeah also i think when you're young
um you want to test your limits of your
body because your
kids think they're invincible because
you kind of are right like you kind of
are
you can you can you can get into a car
accident
and the next day as a young as a 20 year
old i could feel fine
like man yeah we got hit yesterday that
kind of stung my back i got hit a year
ago
and [ __ ] me up for like six months
yeah you know and it wasn't even that
bad of an accident it's just
you test limits of your body when you're
young cause you're flawless you're
you're
you're a machine you know what i mean
you can do you can you can go play
sports you can go work out you can go
get wasted then that afternoon go to a
party stay up till 5am get on a flight
the next day
go with friends somewhere your body
doesn't really react then you get older
and you're whatever your body just your
body slowly just goes nuh uh
oh no dude we're not gonna no your
muscles start to get tighter and you
stretch more it's like
and then young people are always like uh
whatever but then it happens and you're
like oh [ __ ]
if it starts to feel it's you start to
feel like it's
you can't do as much as you used to you
know what it feels like when i like when
a dad
when a dad is like playing sports with
you shooting hoops and he's like oh
my back and you're like what we just
shot we're just shooting around
now sometimes when i'm doing something
i'll go [ __ ] my back
yeah and i know what dad was talking
about it's it's weird man
and you start to like you start to like
whatever you're doing you start to
as you're doing it you know the
repercussions yeah
so you limit what you're doing as you do
it so you're like okay
i'm playing defense this time i'm not
playing defense next time now before
because i don't have you know i can be
in three days i have to do something
right yeah right now if i only have to
do something in four if i do something
in four days then i play defense the
whole game
right right but i gotta do something in
three days so i'm gonna have to kind of
monitor it's gonna be half and half you
go in i'll go in
yeah you do you you like start to
compromise with yourself on what you're
willing to sacrifice but
it does get that i mean dude even
traditionally let's play hoops uh let's
go to let's go to dave and busters
yeah one you know i could go to buffalo
wild wings yeah well watch hoops yeah
let's watch it
you know when you travel for stand up
you don't you feel the same way that
there's days when you travel that
you can handle the plane schedule if
you're jumping around like show to show
to show
but then there's sometimes when city to
city city it just hits me way harder i
don't know why there's some days when
i'm like
more exhausted from the night after
night after night even if i haven't
changed the schedule
yeah you know even if my diet's the same
or i'm not drinking
as much oh yeah it'll still mess me up
sometimes i'll wake up in a city and
just go god
i'm like tired and in pain and i think
when i first started going on the road
dude when i was 22. invincible
please please i drove i drove to montana
and back in a day
i didn't give a [ __ ] yeah remember that
yeah oh it's a 40 hour drive and here i
drove back
got did the stand up got back in my car
and drove right back of course it was
like two or three days in my mind it was
like just did it in a day yeah yeah
because it didn't matter i didn't go to
bed i didn't need to eat
just to tell you other comedians have
two yeah you know i featured out there
in helena
they're like damn really yeah you're
like yep yeah last night big sky baby
last night big sky last night yeah
he's like put your back today drove to
the night couldn't stop dude no money
for hotel had to keep going
caught a good downhill closed my eyes
for a minute threw it in neutral
kick my feet up and just [ __ ] let it
run 4 000 miles later
you would try bro i remember times
thinking okay
uh instead of catching a flight for 217
dollars
i'm gonna rent this car for 19 right
and then drive it
seven hours overnight to get to a
cheaper airport
where it'll where the flight will only
be like 140 that's right
because we need to save that just the
couple of bucks back then meant
everything you needed to save it
because otherwise the time had no value
no not zero because time didn't exist
back then it was like what i didn't need
to be back for anything yeah
it was like if i could if i if i can
waste an extra day getting what i need
done to get to where i need to go
what's the difference i saved the money
you know i didn't lose any money
especially because you're nickel and
diming your way through anything you're
not eating
at nice places you know you're just
you're just going by whatever you need
right
gas station food i survived on gas
station food for years
like i just beef jerky and and uh uh
protein bars and stuff like gatorades
that's what i would just eat from full
meals
i didn't have a dinner till i was like
30. yeah
like i didn't have like a real sit-down
dinner until i was like late in my 20s
and then i started to eat you know
yeah but before that you just you know
you just you lived you lived as
cheaply and efficiently as you could but
now you know
now you can eat a good meal once in a
while yeah when you want i mean i know
you you're out every night
you're out every night no boo malibu
eating sushi you got your own table i
know
they fish live for you don't lie i know
the theo table i've seen it straight to
the table
like the hook to be in there whoever
gets the hook and their cut of fish has
to buy the next meal
[Laughter]
fish out there hook in then you buy do
you ever do credit card roulette have
you ever done that with friends
i now i'm kind of willing to do it but
for years i would see it go
go down and like i can't i can't get it
i hated it i
used to have friends that did it all the
time and it drove me nuts and you have
rich friends
yeah i had a lot of rich friends wow i
went to school with a lot of rich kids
when i was in college
yeah a lot of kids did you go to drake
where'd you go to school i went to i
went to
harvard of the west did you really i
went to arizona state university
yeah that's right a very high acclaimed
university yeah
because i went to university of arizona
yeah for one semester tucson yeah
real sh it's a real [ __ ] oh go ahead
and say it
it is the it's like uh what's the cousin
who has the um
in christmas vacation was the first
eddie yeah yeah that's eddie that's
eddie's campus
yeah hey clark yeah shitter's full yeah
that's exactly right that's that's
that's that's what it is down there
asu was great but yeah i went to school
with guys that had money because they
came from california yeah a lot of guys
that can't get into ivy leagues
and want to move away from where they
are their parents will send them an asu
well because california has so many good
schools and if they don't want to go to
a local school
that isn't that good of a school then
they just go to arizona yeah just
because it's a nice
getaway but it's close enough you know a
lot of pool parties out of cocaine
a lot of pool parties a lot of cocaine a
lot of a lot of
a lot of girls that are tens hooking up
with sub sevens
you know like i'm a six and a half and i
could get eights and nines oh wow yeah
it's great
you were over there eating cheek i was
having a nice dude i was i was eating i
was taking lobster every night
meanwhile i'm denny's you know what i
mean yeah yeah but but
like damn who installed a denny's in
this freaking morton is that a norms
what is that
yeah but but that's that's the funny
thing is like there's so many
uh hot guys and hot girls that at some
point you're gonna get
somewhat you're gonna get something run
off oh sometimes when the hot truck of
girls goes by and hits a speed bump one
of them bounces off
where am i you're here no you ha
at some point it's like you so many
people were so hot that even like a
a not a girl that was a nine or a b so
beautiful yeah
the guys were already with the other hot
girls so she's like you'll be fine like
a nine would have to get like her pupils
dilated for some
condition she had and then you would end
up dating her for a while
yeah and then three months later when
her eyes went back to normal she's like
oh my god yeah
i thought your hair was regular yeah
they never knew like i thought you were
different
yeah me too you were different i thought
you were more symmetrical i didn't know
your face was that lopsided
you had to trap like she'd be like oh
why is your bedroom a wedding chapel
it'd be like
look i got it i have to make ends meet i
got to do what i got doing
i have a marriage in 10 minutes so you
got to get out i need a woman in my life
i gotta do what i gotta do what was your
first what was your first job
out of school out of college yeah what
was your first job do you remember it
i was in college for about nine years it
took me a long time to get you and bert
bert did that yeah but did that i'm
trying to think when i got out did you
you worked your way through college
though didn't you yeah i don't know what
i was doing i was still doing uh you
know i still
that's i was doing mtv when i first
started that so that took up a good bit
of money that's true you were still
doing tv huh
yeah so that stuff was like sometimes it
would take you out of school and then
i would change my pa i would be like all
right i'm going to move
here i'm going to go live here yeah you
know do you talk to any of those people
from mtv
no no none of them it literally feels
like i didn't
it's a different life yeah because when
i met you
i didn't know about any of that stuff
well before that well but but even still
i
even after people referenced it never
knew it yeah like i guess i was not
attuned to it
like i had known what all those popular
shows were i had seen real world when i
was younger and all that stuff but like
when i met you even when i had known
that you had done it in the past
it never registered to me was there any
why
maybe because i never saw you or
anything like that yeah was there a show
that you liked like what's one of your
favorite reality shows every time did
you ever
watch for love or money or any of those
i loved um what was flavor flav's show
oh yeah i [ __ ] loved it
yeah boy when he met new york new york
is crazy son
i love that i thought that [ __ ] was wild
because it was like that dude had no
filter
yeah when i when i first moved here he
didn't give a [ __ ] he gave no [ __ ]
he had yeah like that girl's booty is
too small
and they'd leave it in they didn't mean
that's right he's he bro he is he's
easily
the first black flavor lover to conceive
a child with a 70 year old wife
i know bro and he's ageless this dude is
this dude this dude will laugh look i'm
gonna give you the name
nicorette you because you know right
quitting all these other [ __ ] you
know he'd always have like
weird names right oh your name is booty
hole
your name is booty hole you know he was
dude he was a i when i worked in the
music industry
one of my first day jobs out here let's
refine that statement dude yeah
let's restate it okay i've worked in the
music industry i worked
i worked in the music industry i used to
plan tours yeah my one of my day jobs
was was getting visas for
bands to travel around the world like
tour manager tour uh
scout tour planning this dude what is
that that's howard stern in blackface
he looks like i'm sorry i just thought
he looks exactly like flavor flav
oh yeah oh oh this is how when did he do
blackface huh when did he do
when was that from whenever he won him
man he's got that kind of money yeah i
guess you can just come and come and
you can come and go huh here's the thing
you got to be rich enough to leak your
own bf
photo well here's what's so funny about
blackface like they tried to get jimmy
kimmel recently
right and then he had to like apologize
or whatever i don't think he's going to
be back
you don't think what i don't think jimmy
kimmel is going to be back on the jimmy
kimmel show
no way he might not be back no way
why because the blackface it's not a
real thing
that was so long ago he took off the
whole summer and yep they always take
off the summer the
the late night show hosts and also late
night shows they always take off the
summer they always have a guest break
and uh they do this a lot where they
bring in people i mean this is back to
carson days carson used to
let leno and letterman guest host but
this is not a new thing also he's taking
off the summer to be with his family
i don't think it's because of that i
also think
doing late night right now must suck
look i mean look at they're letting
they're letting our friends do it i know
it's insane and it must suck for the
hosts that
usually do because you're in a studio
with an audience you're used to the
rhythm
now they're doing it from their house or
from a studio that looks like their
house
i'm sure guys like jimmy just aren't
loving that to be real i it has nothing
to do with blackface and i know jimmy
jimmy is the [ __ ]
a hilarious smart cool dude that whole
sketch that they did the blackface
sketch like
give anything context and you'll
understand why they did it right ted
danson in blackface and willie goldberg
was
all supportive of it and was like it was
at my birthday it was a joke
so why didn't ted danson get [ __ ]
ruined well because context means
everything yeah
if you're doing blackface you know uh at
a nazi
hitler party yeah pro hard to talk your
way out of yeah but if you did it for a
tv show sketch get the [ __ ] out of here
what do we talk at some point what are
we talking about well because here also
it's like
if people co-signed it at that time and
nobody said anything like
it's just it just all goes into how
often when what can you go you could go
back to something in everybody's life
always and who are they like obviously
jimmy kimmel it doesn't seem
like he is a person who is uh trying to
like offend but he's had tons of black
people on his television show right
you know right it doesn't add up that oh
he this it's not the same thing
no it's not you know today's episode is
brought to you by better help man better
help
you want to help somebody you want to
help yourself
this is one thing that we can control
during these coveted times
is the amount of of assistance that's
going on
you know and sometimes it's it's us
assisting our friends and being there
for them
and sometimes it's letting others be
there for
us when we really need it when you need
that touch when you need that
that mental fizzle physical connection
when you need somebody to care better
help
i've gotten it i need help i've needed
i need help and i will need help
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional
therapist you know sometimes you know
you live in a place where
oh i don't want to go be seen going into
the therapy center
you know they got a dog out there he'll
bark at me you know my cousin will see
me sneaking in there
to get my brain you know defragmented
to get my heart better but better help
does it all online
there's a broad range of expertise in
betterhelps counselor network
the services available for clients
worldwide
they're committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches
you can get it on your phone you can get
it on text you can
do facetime there's there's many ways to
interact with your new therapist
visit betterhelp.com theo
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash t-h-e-o
and join the over 500 000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced
professional if you're not feeling good
on the inside
take care of yourself this past weekend
listeners will get ten percent off your
first month
at betterhelp.com t t-h-e-o
and now back to the episode listen up
all you business owners and
entrepreneurs
the french in these corvette times
there's never been a better time to step
up your
web game your website to have your
business
prepared for the new world we are
currently living in
you know the old world you go down the
street
you do it you know walk into a licorice
shop and get you a licorice
walk in a roller skate town and get you
know get a skate on your foot
but now it's different now things are
online
and i'm excited to tell you about modify
and their game changing service
that rivals any other option on the
web design market modify
provides a subscription-based
professional web design
service for the cost of your old cable
bill
you know we recently needed a new
website update futurizing
and that's theovonn.com and you can
check it out
modify just finished that new site they
did it
they did the work the site is engaging
it's comforting you're there it's like
being on a swing set in the future on
your front porch
of the moon you can check it out see the
work that they do
but the deal that they offer that's just
as novel
as their style for just 249
dollars a month you will enjoy getting
your website created
and up kept you get the relief of an
easy process
quick turnaround and an evergreen
website
that's right with other professional
services you'll pay ten to twenty
thousand for the same service
every time you need a new site modify
they have you'll have a great personal
design team assigned to your account to
handle all of your website needs
that's unlimited updates unlimited
support easy editing tools and future
redesigns no cost to build no contract
only 249 a month get yours today
at modify.com theo
that's m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot-com slash t-h-e-o
these guys don't have around y'all feel
me there
gang but that's the thing is people
don't care sometimes right they just
want to get infuriated
yeah well but it bleeds over look at
what twitter has done publicly to a lot
of stuff it's turned things
into [ __ ] that never existed right like
look at what's happened to ellen
ellen's getting murdered bro because of
twitter they're saying she might lose
her
you want to talk about someone that
might lose their show not jimmy kimmel
ellen might get [ __ ]
but she's notoriously been a real piece
of [ __ ] but that being said but being a
piece of [ __ ] isn't it
a crime you're right it's not a crime i
don't agree with sir
and but also i don't even know what she
did that's true like my whole thing is
like
did she say um out did she outright say
like i don't hire [ __ ] asians or
derogatory comments out loud right i
don't i don't hire gays i don't hire one
eyes you know don't do that
no so that's true she has the diverse
people on her show every [ __ ] day
well like and also there's a thing about
look at a certain
level of power
at a certain level of prestige right so
a lot of your k your character defects
are going to be magnified
so much like you know there's just no
way to do it like
she's basic it's it's almost like i will
say this it's like a corporation like
people are always like
these big corporations you know they're
killing our you know craft macaroni
killed my son you know even though your
son never you know
he never ate a vegetable his whole life
had nothing to do with it you know he
was in an auto accident
but it's like people always want to
blame big corporations because they get
too big and
they can't manage things at a
comfortable level right that's
i mean ellen is a corporation she is
like a trump tower like she's like a
huge building
she's a business it's not a person
anymore right so if the person on the
first floor of the building
is upset that they don't get treated a
certain way
right you know some of that could be
because there's 40 floors of business
that have been operating
so that whatever trickle down kindness
it's just not there you know well it's
also didn't they didn't they say it was
more her producers than her like from
what i read it was like a lot of
they said the executive producers were
abusive
in their approach or whatever and it
wasn't a lot of her there was a lot of
quotes from
her that i heard about her saying [ __ ]
now whether or not
people say she was mean to them or
disrespectful or whatever
that is what it is but again like we
said like that's not against the law to
be mean
it's not cool but i don't understand
what why can't we just have a talk about
it right do we want people to change and
get better or no
that's a great question do we want
people to change it we just want to burn
them to the ground
because i've yet to find a quote if you
can find it where it's like direct from
ellen said
[ __ ] black people said ellen like i've
never i
haven't seen that yet i've just seen
them yeah [ __ ] dancers [ __ ]
you look at it said alleged racism and
intimidation
yeah that's super vague that's everybody
right dude half my friends are alleged
racists bro and
former employees say ellen's be kind
talk show mantra is a toxic war
culture yeah it's just it's just that's
vague statements that's like anything
else you know who said you know what
somebody said like um
um somebody had a great talk with me
about uh uh
um uh chris hardwick's thing you know
when they said hardwick
his ex said he was emotionally abusive
yeah and and
and who isn't it's hard to be alive but
emotional abuse
what is that that's a really vague term
yeah that's like a step dad
yeah yeah yes yes
like also my wife said this
what what past relationship of yours
your ex wasn't emotionally abusive man
or woman
you hated each other at the end i bet
you were [ __ ] mean to each other when
it was over
what current relationship there isn't
some emotional abuse of course
and manipulation because you guys are
fighting over certain things and
everything is context but we don't know
what was going on inside of that world i
don't know what's going on inside of
that [ __ ] world because like you said
that's a big building dude yeah you're
right
and ellen's in the past on the fire i'm
saying ellen's a piece of [ __ ]
i don't know any different all i yeah i
would here's here's how
you know what else i don't watch the
show so yeah it's another world that i'm
not connected to that
i don't really care about so unless she
outright said
you know filipinos are the lowest rung
of human on earth if she said some [ __ ]
like that then i go damn ellen what the
[ __ ]
that's edgy yeah but until then that's
false true and that's very false because
they're great
they're great it's the thai people that
we don't like everybody knows that
well i don't want to say who it is but
it's the it's this mixes the chinese
they call them the chinese dude
everybody i mean i work with a korean
and i have no we have one in here
sometimes on tuesday oh no
oh yeah try to kill us all north huh huh
who is it
he's uh i don't know if he's north or is
he north or south i don't know either
no papers yeah i work with a korean
every day me and me and robert and i got
to tell you i was never
ever racist towards koreans until i
started working with them but it opens
up a new light
you really start to see you really start
to see who you hate
and that's why i still work with them
because i want to just you keep your
enemies close
and that's bad friends that's bad
friends that's better enemies you're
getting your enemies close
and that's bad friends no i didn't i
think this whole everything can get
pulled out of context
i'll tell you why i even say why i even
think this for one
i'm jealous probably a villain yeah that
she
ha i feel like she's at this point she's
gone to the point where she's taking a
job from a young man
it seems like yeah yeah yeah that's kind
of how although when i see her
i'm like damn yeah she's taking some
young fella's job
young dude's job now i'm not saying
that's a right way for me to think or
feel either but that's
that is the thought that comes with the
second one is a friend of mine used to
work security for
at her house private like personal
security yes and said that she was a
complete [ __ ]
but also now that guy was a nice guy he
was a little bit bow legging honestly no
i don't trust both
people well how did you get that way huh
how'd you get that way
what error did you come from your
parents break your knees when you were
young that freaking polio bad boy or
it's privileged because you rode horses
or animals a lot if you wrote a lot of
animals you can get bow-like
well if you wrote a real small animal
then you're and you're like us yeah yeah
you don't get bo like it but if you're
privileged you get to ride big animals
big more bow you bow up yeah that's the
bigger the bigger the bow the bigger the
privilege that's what i say
and so that's where a lot of my you know
i guess my disdain comes from and i
think i just have a general disdain
sometimes for that culture now if she
asked me to be on her show next weekend
i might have a different opinion i don't
think you would go you know i don't
think you would go on ellen
i don't know i i just imagine if she
asked you to dance
would you go out there dancing all the
way down the aisle
no theo vaughn
and that dj and the dda is like what's
up ceo and you have to do that thing
you're like what up dog yeah you gotta
do that
stanley hey uh hey diverse person i can
just even imagine yeah i don't even need
to know who the dj is
like hey diverse person he's like what
up what up
but would you go on there you would on
ellen yeah no
i i couldn't i would have no business
what would i do on ellen well i mean you
know like more of an actor you do acting
yeah but they're i mean you know if
anybody from my show they would have
little dicky they would have like i'm
not the star of that show even if i was
the star of a show
ellen wouldn't be where i would go to
promote the show because
nothing i would make would be ellen's
audience right ellen's audience is
moms middle-aged women mostly you know
yeah like it doesn't they wouldn't like
me
you know like the content i put out
that's not
what they like at all i mean right kudos
to those that are broad enough but
right i think what we make is a little
bit more specific than that acting or
not
it'd be too hard they'd be like oh i
don't like the language he used
on this podcast i heard so no what would
i go on
i mean i would i would slit a throat to
be on stern would you
i love stern i've always loved the guy i
mean like i love the show i've done the
i've done the wrap-up show because
yeah yeah yeah and those guys are
[ __ ] john those guys are a dope
they're the nicest and they have the
most fun they don't give a [ __ ] there's
no rules
they kind of let you be you sometimes
you go on shows and they like dictate
how you're supposed to be you know when
they shut you out
and they don't make you feel welcome and
you're like all right well i guess
you know i'm just filling a gap for two
minutes
but those guys let you do it i just i
want to be on that on the show one day
to talk to him
that's a good goal man you know what
sometimes i feel like i i i keep myself
out of my own goals yeah with judgment
why
you know i don't know would you go on
would you want to be on howard
hmm i don't know if i would i mean
i don't know if it do you like him at
all
i like him just not a big fan you like
him just fine yeah
i used to i used to be a massive fan and
then just time wise i don't get to
listen to it anymore because i'm not in
my car listening to sirius anymore
yeah but i used to love it you know what
i loved about the guy honestly that
in the sake of how we're comedians and
we can joke around like i did before i'm
joking about not liking koreans and my
one of my best friends is korean totally
we can throw that away and have a joke
and then go back to something real right
he does that a lot which i like that
he's able to just go [ __ ] it if you
can't tell the difference and when i'm
kidding and when i'm not
that's on you like get [ __ ] get real
like yeah he used to be a lot more like
that i feel like
well i mean he's definitely a legend
getting i think it also he's getting
older and it's
getting harder the show is obviously
getting harder to do it's
it's tough you're you're you're co
you're making content every day
all of it's tough yeah that's hard i i
just think and you changed too
yeah yeah he's probably not the same
person he was 20 years not even close
he's like a vegan who paints and does
yoga
you know i mean like yeah he he's
completely changed which has it's cool
to watch his
he's a jewish diamond dallas page really
he's jewish huh is he jewish howard
stern oh god i'm not listening anymore
i didn't know yeah i didn't know
imagine 25 years old oh no
no he is he is he's the jewish
john mcdowell's face are you a wrestling
guy all the jokes that we do about
wrestling do you watch it
oh this the truth is man if i had to be
real honest there was a guy in our
i don't want to say our neighborhood but
in our probably an adjacent neighborhood
that trained
wrestlers when i was growing up really
yeah and did you get trained huh no but
i'd go watch
you go check it out i'd try to get in
there and i got the britches one time
for uh
you know chris chris or something yeah
and it was they got me some shitty ones
you know they had they got me in one
with the ballet surplus or whatever so
i'm wearing some [ __ ]
little billy elliotts out there
hand-me-downs oh yeah yeah
i look like a damn newsie you know i
look like a news
selling papers and watching training i
look like a newsy at the gym you know
but i'd go over there and watch them you
know and the guy had a ring set up in
his own yard you know
when they'd throw him off the ropes and
do the body slam you know
i love that and they had a uh this one
wrestler guy who was
i don't want to say mentally disabled
probably had autism before they had
autism so it was
like oh that guy's a [ __ ] you know
strong yeah and it would be like this
guy fireboy was his uh
wrestling thing you know and he had like
uh the pants yeah with the flames on the
side
and some kind of doc martens but before
doc martens you know nurse martin's you
know
right this guy had like these lace-up
boots and he wrote fireboy on each one
you know
and i'd go over there and watch him
train the guy are you sure
huh are you sure it wasn't andrew uh
yeah it could have been was it me
fireboy what if it would have been but
dude i'll tell you i'll say this and
i'll say this again man
i i still don't understand why some of
the podcast people do not
make a wrestling script
with this i know when you talk about
this i don't have any wrestling in my
blood though
who cares yeah but i don't i don't even
enjoy it it's not for me
then you can still do it have you seen
wrestling dude i know but there's
something about wrestling characters i
don't like time you've ever been angry
at a costume party
yeah that's wrestling bro i know i mean
no i have i got no fight with a guy at a
costume party
that's wrestling dude it's just the
halloween yeah but we really fought
yeah oh that's good we're really fun
then that's not right we've really got
no fistfire no i don't like i don't like
um
i never i nev when i was a kid i thought
hulk hogan was cool
and i thought some of the wrestlers were
cool but i never followed it
because something didn't click with me i
didn't like
i don't think i like the boots and the
pants i don't like
i didn't like tight pants on men and
boots yeah
i don't know yeah like well they're in
jeans i guess i could do it if they were
all wearing jeans
and this guy he's his whole thing is
like apathy he doesn't take his hands
out of his pocket he kind of hates the
whole thing that could be you
that's me i'm just happy i'm just yeah
apathetic
apathetic andrew tommy dreamer well see
that's my thing you know i know they
actually slap him too
carl lentz the pastor yeah
yeah i just it's not for me yeah this is
getting weird
it's not for me yeah something about it
misses for me it's just like um
look and i like theatrics i like i i
know
i know that it's all a big play i think
it's cool
the idea is cool um well it's things
some things have gone on have have have
have gone on too long sometimes which
are institutions
have gone on too long i do think a lot
of times but then some things go
went away for no reason do you know what
highlight is
i've seen that scooper highlight yeah
you know that was most famous it was
one of the most popular sports in the
world at one time no way yes
yes one of the most one of the most
spectated sports
in the world at one point in time
especially because in india it was huge
you're talking
you know but highlight they try to make
a comeback it just it it's not working
it's never going to come back
but that's jory cornbed he's one of the
most famous really yeah
but this game is [ __ ] insane i mean
they're going it's in a court
yeah and the balls get thrown 170 miles
an hour or something
it's just it's a wild but it's a wild
cool sport to watch
but it'll never it'll never come back i
can't tell you why
i don't know what the appeal i don't i
don't know why it lost this cool appeal
of watching people do that just huck
that ball
when you listen to the echo of the ball
off the wall too it's daunting it's like
really it's crazy but look at how hard
they
[ __ ] whip that thing you get hit in
the face with that you're gone bro
oh they gotta wear the helmet too yeah
but people get hit all the time really
yeah
people get hit all the time it's fun
that's
that kind of stuff but it look but that
loses its luster
right it's gone but now what about
female roller derby did you ever watch
that when it was on tv
all the kids but they hurt each other
that's why i love that yeah see i love
the
the physical real pain
i love to watch someone get clipped or
taken out yeah that's why i love
football same thing
i'll tell you one time i went to the usc
stadium yeah and it was super bowl
day and they had the women's
tackle football going on down there
right it was like half time i think they
were doing like i don't know something
during that day they were putting on a
game
and it's pretty lame to say you know i i
forgo watching the super bowl i guess it
was two teams i didn't care about or
something
and i went down there to watch that
women's tackle football game
yeah and they lit each other i love it
you've seen you've seen lingerie
football you've seen that right maybe
that's what it was it was
yes okay so that's what it was it was
hot with the pads on
some of these chairs you should pull up
that highlight reel of those girls
they clip each and there's also they're
they're
they're able to get away with more the
nfl doesn't let anymore like horse
collar you can still horse collar in
that
there was a pigtail on the on the on the
thing after it
i mean look at that she's throwing she's
blatantly throwing her shoulder
yeah at her neck you know like
oh get the
[ __ ] out of here get the [ __ ] out of
here wow
dang that girl and shield and somebody
they just are
straight fighting some of these chicks
will shoot they'll shoot up right into
the middle of the tit
i think they're i think i think fighting
is all legal too i think it's legit
oh
damn this is it's an incredible game
this should be way more popular
bro i'm getting mildly erect brother i
really am
which is good because i actually ended
up masturbating yesterday so to get an
erection the day after
that's really good you're able to fill
up again oh
i can't get in i can't get a tank in
that fast very rare so i didn't know
this was going to do it for me
this is it now i know how to pique your
interest ooh
now some of the ass cheeks get a little
small the stronger the women get well
yeah you got if you yeah you can't hold
out all that weight
some of the running backs
[Laughter]
oh yeah filler up dude see this is a way
to handle daddy issues if you're don't
go stripping
get out on the field and beat the [ __ ]
out of another girl now the problem i
think is just the money
they don't get paid enough i'm sure they
don't get paid [ __ ]
yeah well there's no there's not enough
money to be made you know like you got
to have more fans
but that's the thing it's like this
should be a bigger sport there should be
a way bigger sport
dude you know what i just realized
sometimes i don't even really want to
have sex i just want to put my penis in
there
just it just let it sit and soak no just
get as long as you get it in it's like
it's yeah they call it soaking
that's enough really yeah yeah yeah
really hardcore uh
mormons mormons will call it's called
soaking wow they're allowed to put it in
they just can't they just can't make
friction
yeah you got it it's hard though you're
gonna sneak it in there and let it sit
for an operation
don't touch the sides
you gotta let it soak for a while dude
that's scary bro yeah
you do you gotta let it sit because the
thrusting is a lot of work right oh it's
all a lot of work dude have you ever
worked at brenda's shop it's a lot
that's a lot of work that's an uphill
like atlas that guy who pushes that ball
up that hill you ever seen that guy from
greek mythology and it always keeps
falling down on him yeah and no matter
how close you get to the top it's gonna
it's always coming and then no
that's that's why is that ball that's
sisyphus right sisyphus never was able
to get it up there big boy
was like why does this ball of a thick
boy bite club shirt
dude he loves the biking huh dude it's
crazy i was like is he sponsored by bike
is bike sponsoring him i feel like he he
got so into bikes overnight oh he's like
yeah bro i'm [ __ ] 25 miles today up
to sound like good for you dude
dude yeah i'm phony hulk that's it dude
he will
that's the thing about brendan people
knock him the one thing that he is
that that inspires me is that he is a
hard worker yes he's committed
who else can go from one thing to the
next
right he jumps all right find their
footing in it football
fighting comp podcasting comedy
and biking and freaking biking he gets
sponsored by bike
the company bike it's like q-tip really
all the bikes sponsored him wow
any bike company he wants thick boy his
instagram has become like an autistic
kid's instagram it'll just be like big
snake on road
here's a danger noodle yeah yeah he
posts a steak like he hasn't seen he's
you've seen one every day it's not a
mystery anymore now it's it's a nuisance
to me i'd go god
for these [ __ ] snakes he's like whoa
here's another sand winder
whoa the best is
uh the other day he's like flag sounds
of some lady biking
he flags her down and let her know
there's a snake there and she doesn't
give a
[ __ ] she's like whatever loser and just
drives by
is he into motorcycles does he do is he
is he up there yet he is it's on his
calendar but i don't know i think it's
2022.
2022. he'll get into those sit bikes you
know with the big sides
like the mexicans have out here yeah
yeah the beach beach cruisers yeah oh no
no i'm talking about the ones where the
older people
yeah and it has like the little case on
the thing for a gatorade yeah a little
picnic basket in the side yeah oh yeah
what got your sandwich in there honey
you want a bologna i got your bologna
bologna extra mayo he's gonna get he's
gonna ask me why he said this about him
i know but it's all it's all because
he's addicted when he gets involved in
something
it becomes obsessive he's obsessed with
biculture now
now it's like it's not like where you
say if you were like
yeah man i just got into you know uh uh
jiu jitsu like if you just got into it
i'm sure you would like it and really
get into it
but it wouldn't consume me like when
brennan gets into something it's like
all-consuming again yeah he's a he's an
athletic
addict right he's addicted to athletics
or he buy the chef's hat or
and then he gets a spoon right right and
then he gets the knives and he wants to
make the knives yeah
then he gets the cheese grater and he
does it all right you know then he grows
then he starts making his own cheese
yeah right this guy gets all the way in
i like things but then i can't get if i
get too involved
i know i'll go crazy yeah so i have to
from a distance you know
if you've ever walked into a to a scent
establishment to get that smell to get
that upper on your body
get that you know you want something
that smells good across your body
you know it used to be the old days you
would carry something with you that
smelled good
you'd carry a rose or carry a muffin
something to get the other sex or the
same sex depending on what you love
to come over to you or to get anything
to come over to you you wanted to have
some kind of scent
something coming off of you well i want
to tell you right now that
hawthorne is the company that cares
about how you smell and the essence
that you give off into the world you
know i'm still using the same cologne
that i had when i was in high school
you know probably it's i think it's
called ralph lauren
ck one online polo sport
the same one everybody has right but
hawthorne now has a quiz that can help
you find
an updated scent that really caters to
who you are
the quiz is uh it's really it's
personalized
so they ask you know how do you how do
you smell usually you know what type of
body style do you have what's your hair
style
you know what's your what's your skin
grade how does it feel how does it look
you know how moisture how moisture do
you like your skin
it really it gets to know you you know
how's your body odor what do you have
on a you know on a scale of this to that
it really gets to know you and then it
hits you with those two
two examples of hey this is what you
need to really show up and to show out
and a smell good that's right hawthorne
it's personalized premium quality
ingredients
convenient and they're easy to buy right
there online
luxurious packaging it's everything you
want
in those feel-good body condiments
you take the two-minute quiz it's
totally risk-free with
free shipping and free returns
check out hawthorne.co
that's h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
and use promo code theo to get 10
off your first purchase that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot o and use code
theo to get ten percent off your first
purchase hawthorne dot co
you wanna smell good you wanna feel good
you just gotta update it's time to
update
you know if you want a new life and you
want to attract new things
you need to go into it with a new body
attitude
and hawthorne will give you that what do
you think about when you see these guys
doing the drive-in shows and some of
these new opportunities that are coming
up for stand up
i talked to segura about it okay but
i'll be real with you when i say this i
know this sounds annoying but
i think stand-up isn't going to come
back for
a long time and i mean it from a
personal level i've done so much
searching
inside about it i just don't think it's
going to be the same when it does come
back
so i was talking to schultz last night
about this and i was like man
you know what we're making this kind of
stuff this is our stand-up
current future right now oh yeah because
this is more fun
than trying to do a digital show to me
you know and perform to an audience
that's not there
because this is the same they're there
they're watching but i don't have to
wait for their response or know that
they're
engaged they can engage on their own who
are they
who the audience yeah you know who yeah
who yeah who's ever watching whenever
they're watching this
but like those live shows on zoom and
all that
i just don't know if it's for me i've
been offered a few times i don't know
that i can
i don't know if that's my [ __ ] but the
drive-in shows the the
you know bert's doing i called him too
and i talked to him about it he's having
a lot of fun we were trying to plan a
tour with me and bobby to go do that and
it just didn't work out the schedules
was too hot it was too hard and
to get to one city the next and it cost
a shitload of money to put those on
outside
because these aren't pre-established
venues it's not like going to a club
that the building's already there this
with the lights and the sound and
they have to build this [ __ ] outside and
they're hoping that multiple
people of like us do it so they can keep
the venue up
keep the permits but it's still it's
very costly so
you think you'd be able to go and set up
a tent you know yeah but even still
you got to pay sat staff you have to
have union you have to sound engineers
you have to
people who build stages i mean you know
it's just kind of like you gotta grease
the constable
you know yeah yeah you got the the local
small town yeah
yeah you have to hit somebody off and
then even still they're gonna want to
hit they're gonna want to be hit
what they should have got from the union
yeah either way no matter how you shake
it
i don't know if it's worth it for me
right now if i was
as big as bert or segura yeah yeah maybe
if it's worth it for them to go
get 500 cars in a parking lot i don't i
don't i just don't know
also i feel weird inviting people to go
out and not be able to touch them and
and interact with them and see them and
be you know have that those moments in a
room
when you're with people it's just
irreplaceable and i i don't know yeah
cause i'm sure
you know i got invited the other day to
do a show where the televisions are in
front of there's a guy
yeah they invited me to yeah yeah yeah
yeah great guy puts on a lot of awesome
shows
yeah and and apparently there's like 20
screens in front of you where you can
see the audience actually
see them right there in front of you
that's interesting yeah it is no it's
cool i did tell them i said it looked
really
cool but i um i'm also i also know my
habits
as a performer and i don't know if that
would cater to my habits i really
enjoy feeding off like the live energy
of people yeah i'm significantly better
in in pressure situations where it's
live and big
oh yeah than i am and those where
there's almost no pressure because it's
digital there's a lot of
growing room and you know it's almost
like there's almost no pressure
which i don't really like like i think
the pressure of live is why i like it so
much it's like we paid to see you [ __ ]
you better rip
yeah and when you do it's like it works
you know
whereas there there's a disconnect and
it's okay if it doesn't work great
because
both people know that this is a weird
medium of comedy
yeah that's interesting it's almost
caters it almost seems like it caters to
the that the reward the reward isn't
actually being
could the reward isn't actually being
funny the reward is
their kindness because then people might
act like they're laughing
or laugh out of like you know yeah one
of those things but yeah just because
that's how they're supposed to look like
they're behaving because you're not
going to be able to hear their audio
right they're just going to hear you
so then it's going to become this world
where you're performing for virtually
for people everybody's pretending that
they're having a good time
because they paid to be there and it's
just going to be
so i'm worried about that i'm just
waiting i think it's i think it's i
think it's good for people that are
doing it that it's it's working for them
because there are people so i'm not
hating right no i'm not hating because i
might do it i just wonder if the reward
if it's creating a reward system that is
different than the
original being on stage and getting
you know and feeling that moment between
you and them and
forcing a laugh you know like some
people laugh because they have
there's it's not they're laughing
because they want to they laugh because
you
the rhythm yes you did it you made them
laugh you did the job
whereas if it just looks like i'm
supposed to be assert doing a certain
thing
then i might just do that thing well
because you know how people they always
talk about how people react when they
know a camera's watching there
so you know like someone in the streets
you know they're going to react
different if they have a camera on them
they start to function different
their eyes their their movements
everything becomes
hyper aware that they're on camera so
when they're on camera watching you they
know you see them now
versus in the room you don't see
audience members
you just hear them if they're laughing
they're laughing and if they don't like
the joke they'll sit there and smile
politely
you know if they if they're not a fan of
the joke they're like oh you know and
those guys you can tell usually
i bet they hit their girlfriends there's
always that guy 100 there's always that
guy you see up front and you kind of
look at the girl and just
i always look at her and let her know
it's okay and if you need to go we can
go
yeah just you know i know what's going
on you should have a help code when you
start the show
ladies if you're here with your man and
he's abusive and he doesn't want to be
here yeah
you know we should have a help code
order that salmon yeah
i'll take a salmon then i know you're
ready to go yeah you come with me we'll
save you
yeah there's always there's always a guy
or two at the show that's not enjoying
the show
because he's mad that you're doing the
thing that he doesn't do
right he hates his job or whatever and
he's annoyed that his friends like you
and he's like i'm not really a fan
yeah but i came with them but they love
you but whatever good to me it was so it
was pretty funny
yeah yeah you're not stand up i don't
think is going to come back for
i don't know summer next year i i think
the vaccine has to be the thing
to give people the the i think to give
people the comfort level it's more about
comfort
i start to do you start to feel i
started to feel this this week like
every monday
i start to feel like wow okay
we get a little further from the
existence that we knew
sundays usually make my old lady
depressed because
work on monday is like a whole thing for
her you know that's like a startup again
it's like oh [ __ ] i have a big week
ahead of me and i never got it
because our weeks bled together right we
don't really know what you know it's
like i've got shows every night of the
week or we're on the road
so monday and sunday weren't significant
days but they are now because sunday
to me is this end of a week for me and
monday is like
how many more of these weeks are gonna
happen without us having
the ability to go do whatever i need to
do because i was saying it i feel like
forced retirement
i don't like it i feel like i've been
forced to retire from stand up
you know it's kind of like if you meet
someone that retires too early
they usually get depressed yeah you
don't get to do the thing that you love
i have no outlet i can't go work out at
night it kills me
you know it kills me out to go to the
club and work out new shitty jokes but
now what are things
yeah yeah i feel you i start to feel
like okay the interesting thing is each
time i started to i just finally started
to notice i was like oh man i'm starting
to think like
we're getting further away from the life
that we knew
to the point where it's interesting this
new one becomes
this is it the norm this is it get strap
strap in this is it
because it part a lot of me still thinks
oh this is just such a temporary thing
no i don't think so anymore but you
start or do you feel that too a little
bit where you like
it slips away whatever was before starts
to slip away and this
slowly becomes about a month ago i've
therapeutically admitted to myself
and people around me friends and family
that i'm like the new norm is
gonna be we're never gonna go back to
what it was this is going to be future
no no way i don't i really don't i think
i think we will inherently time will
change us for the better
we will adapt people this is all going
to change
i don't i don't i think jumping back
into what we thought was normal will
never happen ever again
i just don't think so it'll be a new
normal but it will be okay as well that
will also be
but we will function significantly
differently i mean you look at anything
like
any kind of any kind of uh societal turn
right a big flip whether it's you know
the internet and the takeover
of what the internet did yeah or flu or
something
well but anything that's just a big
change in our society
inherently changed us forever and we did
it yeah we did it we did it okay yeah we
did it fine
we fixed it we we created new jobs
because of it right the industrial
revolution
created [ __ ] an entire new society
for us did it create other problems and
put other things out
out of business yeah is stand up gonna
go out of business power no
[ __ ] change the whole world
everything everything the power hammer
yeah didn't work oh the jackhammer but
it was yeah yeah but it led to the
jacket it led to the jackhammer right
the first one the power hammer was not
you pull up power hammer power hammer
didn't work jack hammer worked power
hand hammer
power hand hammer yeah
yeah i think i think we're gonna
function at a higher level in a
different way that's all
we just have to find new ways to do it
which is why i applaud the people doing
the [ __ ] uh
doing the those shows online because
it's in you gotta try you gotta swing
the bat
right try it yeah i think the reason why
i haven't gotten into the
end of the shows online is because i'm
like are there enough of these yet where
i can go and do
two and three in a night or do a bunch
right so that i can actually like
cultivate the material and like you know
uh
ruminate it as opposed to just going and
doing a one-off you know
are you going to dump all the old stuff
that you weren't that you had that you
were doing before or no
well i have a i have a special with
netflix set up so yeah hopefully i'll
dump it into there
but when's that going to be filmed right
see that's what i feel like
that's a good question but at a certain
point they'll just be like they're going
to need material
they're just going to be like look shoot
it at a you know starbucks yeah yeah
shoot it yes cold brew cold brew for
micah
you're slinging joked i just think i
think but i think they need to but i
think this is a good opportunity for
netflix
to film or let people film at very
unique
and different places instead of a
traditional theater instead of like
let's do it at a different kind of venue
right yeah i think about that but then i
think you see outdoors ones are just no
not outdoor do an indoor one
well bring up that boat thing that nick
that what's his name had in here
who that hand hammer never worked
never ever power crank look at that
concepts yeah remember that thing that
uh
tim dillon had the boat the drive-in
boat show
this guy's so funny i loved him it's
unbelievable with stuff he says
he goes yeah well he shoots for the moon
he sounds like rose limbaugh he is he's
he's argent he's our generation's rush
yeah except he's sober now yeah rushes
on pills
yeah rush is peeled out but here's
something equipped social distancing
boats coming to los angeles love it
floating cinema yeah great that's just
rich people yeah if you're rich enough
that's great dude here's the crazy thing
that rich people do too oh let's go to
this graveyard and watch a movie
love it oh you [ __ ] on the dead yeah you
let him know that you're above him yeah
espio have you ever been there to
hollywood forever cemetery cenespian
that's what i said one time yeah i love
my heart though seeing that all these
rich people having a little
cheese on top of [ __ ] you know henry
ford or something
and stuff like that yeah i love that i
love eating on old dead hollywood people
it just shows how little we mean right
it shows how this town
this town you mean nothing you mean
something you mean something for this
long and then you're ellen and then they
kill you
and then you go sit on ellen's grave and
you watch you know
but isn't that part of the thing you
know it's like they built
now it's become such a system they build
you up
yeah and then they tear you down yeah
they're excited for it
but we've always done that yeah i think
i think yeah look at the bible even
yeah they want they want they have to
take down someone that's at the top
because it feels uh you raise someone up
because you're impressed and then when
you have societally raised them up then
you get tired of
their success because inherently they
have more than you they're
they're they're it's they're bigger than
you yeah so they have to kind of peel
you down a little bit
and it almost and we all need to be para
it's like
we're all imperfect in the end so it's
like we have
it the truth is yeah that there is a
damn there's a
there's all a down life i mean death is
the day you know death is a
the whole story ends
with an arc you know it's a high and
then a low right the story ends with us
in in a field with someone younger
eating cheese on top of us watching a
movie
yeah that's how the story ends that's
okay as long as you enjoyed it when
you're
above the ground i feel like i'm cool
with
however the story goes as long as i
am putting forth effort to make it go
somewhere yeah because it's never going
to be
you're never going to have a oh the
whole time
you know what is your industry going to
be like in the acting world because i
know you guys
show dave got picked up for season two
yeah we're supposed to we supposed to
already have been shooting it it should
be almost done by now i think shooting
wow
technically yeah we'll probably not do
it i mean they keep saying november but
i don't think so
i think we'll probably do it next year
and who knows i don't know
luckily our show is for hulu i mean
it's fx but it's hulu because they're
one now
and so we're digital which is i think
where tv lives anyway
tv's digital dude i don't here's a guy
right here he's got a question
what does he say
is brendan's son who had the idea in
dave
for you guys to have a bath scene
and you wash his back
there's a scene in the dave show where i
get in the tub with him and we're naked
and i wash his back
we are really naked in the chute yeah
and you know what that wasn't supposed
to be on camera that was that was a
moment of
dave and i kind of having a bonding and
they put it on the show and i don't know
if i appreciated that i think they went
they kind of went above and beyond
um artistic integrity there because we
said we're kind of working the
characters we're trying to figure out
what we need
from each other in the scene so i would
it was a long day it was the end of the
day
i said i'm going to take a bath in this
house that we were shooting and he said
i'd love to take a bath as well there
was only one bath
i said we'll share a bath but i want a
closed set
they put cameras in there damn it's a
little disturbing but that's what the
business does yeah
they're invasive nothing like putting
two men together and getting them naked
yeah
in this town and this in this town
that's that's really what happens
yeah you know and they filmed it and it
was my choice and
i don't enjoy that they filmed it and
put it out there dude i'll tell you a
story that happened to me i remember i
just remember this when i first got into
town
some man set me up with a guy who was an
agent
right some agent guy i know what this is
he's like i'll take you to this party or
something so he takes me to a party cuba
gooding jr is there so i'm all excited
he's always there yeah then the guy's
gonna give me a ride drop me back off my
place and even have a car yet right and
i remember the guy saying if you grab my
dick while i drive
my car will go faster did it uh
i didn't touch him oh but i remember
just didn't want to see if it could go
fast
but we've been doing a little bit of
coke you know and i remember thinking uh
first i was like that's insane i don't
you know that sounds
you know that sounds fake yeah i don't
know if i don't know if there's a
correlation between his penis and
i didn't even realize that the guy was
trying to be
perverted or homoerotic or anything i
didn't realize any of that i just
thought oh this guy
he has a big car he's a gear head this
guy's a real gearhead yeah yeah
but dude i said it twice and then i
remember i remember just having to stand
up for myself you know
yeah at some point i love women dude i
gotta i still had a picture of my
girlfriend in my wallet
showed him you know look at shannon but
he didn't want to see huh he didn't you
know
that killed him bro yeah he's like you
sure that's not shawn yeah that's not a
sean
but i forgot about that man i guess it's
that kind of town where they want you to
be in a bathtub with a man
yeah well and that's that's exactly
right and when you do want to do it on
your own volition and not have it filmed
they end up putting it on a television
show yeah that's the problem
i got proposed to by a uh a proposition
by
a guy who was trying to be my manager
really yeah he said i'll only take eight
percent but you have to make up the two
percent in other ways
and i said what other ways he said i
want a kissy kiss every time
you drop off money from a job and
i just was appalled by the even the idea
to kiss him
dropping off a check my money to him and
kissing him yeah but
so after two or three years i had to
drop him i just couldn't do that [ __ ]
anymore especially a kissy kiss
a kissy kiss well yeah because that's
one on the cheek and one on the lips
that's a kissy kiss
the nerve of this guy you know that's
sneaky that's like when your grandmother
was like in her last year of life she
[ __ ] sneaks one in
on you here's a kiss yeah give me a
little kiss let me get that double up
yeah come on nana stop it hit it on the
lips hit me on the lip smell like that
we smell like
old artichokes
why does everybody feel so cold uh
what else we got nick yeah uh i wanted
to bring
up uh andrew clatt back when you had tom
on your instagram
i was commenting from the king and the
sting instagram oh yeah what did you say
i said the show should just be called
bad
right which i was pretty proud of
actually but yeah hit him pretty hard
he's self-promotion
i like it though yeah this is nick i'm
helping out king of steak
comment whoring gets you a lot of
followers right but uh
then he clapped back and he said uh well
your show should be called yeah man and
coveted boy
yeah man what are you saying yeah man
and cobra well here's one of my
favorites too man well you know we
i got you know i got a lot of hate for
this by the way from bobby bobby tom
came on as a guest on
no no no no no no no yeah tom came on
whiskey ginger
and we went to the bad friend studio and
tom this was tom's idea
to say that he's going to replace bobby
bobby
i'm not kidding was [ __ ] livid i was
like it's a joke
he's like it's not funny it's not
[ __ ] funny you think you just
replaced me i was like bob
we're kidding if tom of course is not
gonna do the show yeah that's joking
but also bobby was mad so
he's bobby's so oddly fragile he's so
fragile
he's just a delicate little he's like
something you get at the airport and
it's like nice but you're like how do i
keep this i got to go two flights you
have to hold it the whole flight didn't
put it in a bag i'm tired i'm gonna go
to sleep i took a pill
you fall asleep for two seconds it's on
the floor and it's cracked already
yeah i had to do i had to do a little
clap back into the king and the sting
rename your show yeah man and culver boy
well that was good
there's another one that's really good
too go to uh
a different pitcher go to go back to his
main uh
and cheetos santino's you can where you
can follow andrew i'm sure a lot of you
guys already do but
um there was another one you posted
i said that you commented on yeah i
can't remember which one you said
something on
go down a little more maybe or if not
it's that one in the middle maybe right
if i just dylan on our laps if i scroll
down on instagram
through his page it'll probably just
you'll be the type of show where it is
that uh uh okay yeah whatever you think
is best nick that's dylan that's me
and then me rogan and krish are holding
dylan on our laps you know what's so
funny like that is a picture that
genuinely makes me go
god damn i miss hanging out with friends
doing stand-up and [ __ ] around
i mean what like i really that's the
kind of stuff that genuinely when i
scroll past sometimes
it just makes me a little you know a
little soft i go [ __ ] i'm just hanging
out and saying hi to people
i think we didn't know how good oh i
think everybody
and this includes everybody for their
own walk of life everybody didn't know
how good we had it oh we had it so good
we did whatever we wanted
is the freest country in the world we're
allowed to do whatever we want all the
time
and then when this happens here you just
goes to show you how restrictive life
can be
when something gets in your way i mean
oh yeah what can you do no we're almost
yeah i feel like we're damn
which one was it go down a little bit
more it couldn't have been that further
away because we just he
i remember it just happened okay i don't
remember what it was was that on your
personal account or whatever if it was
bad
it could have been the bad friends
account yeah maybe
maybe it was bad friends it could have
been i was like oh i got asked to do
this show
oh i'm glad bobby found somebody to do
to do this show with him that's what it
was
that's what it was maybe it's a bad
friends episode maybe on that one
no you know what go back to my profile i
bet you it was
that same picture i'm telling you i bet
you the exact same picture with tom
and you said i got i think theo i think
you said i got asked to do this show
i got us to do this show and i said you
already do a show with a handicapped guy
yes
shout out brendan shaw man shout out to
shannon shout out bar door
yeah that's our boy we love barney
barnyard showers
he's gonna get freaking mad no he's not
yes he will he's not because he knows
how much of we love him that's true
you're right you're right
he knows love there's a big difference
also what did what did uh
go back up in that scroll that what did
uh let me i'm gonna ask you this though
look at that what
oh i thought that was somebody else
never mind i was like who did i thought
that was george
who could fight it might be up at the
top yeah it usually does how why does it
should call it just bad oh
he did that if you think you get no keep
going yeah that's you again
mistake rick and his alcoholic burn
victim friend look at that
nick kept throwing punches he should but
did i comment after that and i commented
that one i don't know
no because i was busy and that is theo's
line alcoholic burn victim i gotta
yeah yeah i know i know i like that
that's what i love and that's when the
rat king shows up dude when he's gotta
freaking defend his well he doesn't have
a choice at some point yeah
uh do you think who do you think's gonna
win this election do you think
it's interesting yeah now i changed my
opinion i used to think
um i genuinely used to think
not and i'm not saying i'm not putting
you on a political side or anything i'm
just talking this openly who do we think
could win this election no no no no it's
not a political thing i used to think
trump was going to win for sure i
thought i thought in my mind i was like
there's just no way
because he was so polarizing and and he
it just was controlling the country
keep that up nick and then now i don't
think so anymore i just don't
i think in lieu of what's going on i
don't think so who won the 2020
presidential election
and this is over the past year
what the percentage is yeah see there
you go yeah that's what i was going to
say
there you go i still don't know i i
don't think he will anymore due to the
fact that
well he bombed during the black lives
matter thing he didn't
between blm and the pandemic i think are
a perfect storm for him to
cause him to lose yeah do you know what
i mean i think that's what i'm i think
those two things will make it go
nick is just checking his fantasy stuff
it's always checking in
no i know i laid a couple of years ago i
laid money on trump
on 2020 yeah what did you put down i put
down 250
that he'd win again yeah and it was like
10-0 was there a parlay do you get what
i saw the same thing it was before he
had won the pr the the
republican the first the republican
nominee he was plus 800 and like
you knew he was going to win that so at
that point it's 50 50 essentially
like what are the odds right now for
biden and him uh it's like uh
biden's the favor those are let's see
them those yeah
sorry nick no no no no yeah i do want to
see this i do want to see the favorites
because that's why
i think minus one fifty thirty five wow
well see that's silly why would they
throw why would they throw in hillary
clinton and michelle obama because
here's what happens
just in case if biden can't make
physically cannot do it
the electoral college gets to pick yeah
uh or the is it the representatives the
there's a group that gets to then put
somebody in his yes
sure i mean the dnc then gets to replace
right the dnc then gets to put somebody
instead that's why a lot of people still
think
and i've thought this the whole time
that hillary clinton is going to slip in
at the last minute
and uh and replace him or somebody is
but michelle obama has never even talked
about being up
she's just i don't know she just
launched a podcast on spotify tv yeah
that's because they want to get paid
2024. they got they got seven emmy
nominations from their
look the obamas have parlayed
their presidency into being media moguls
now oh yeah
intelligently so if you're gonna get out
of being a president you can't just play
golf and sew
because they're still young they did the
thing that
you would do if you were that young
you'd go well let's get a media deal
with netflix for a hundred million
dollars
make [ __ ] employ people and keep making
money
what about this and here's a here's a
different question what do you think the
effects of the pandemic
will have on how people vote
that's what i start to wonder because i
start to wonder if a lot of people think
that we're going to head towards
socialism
yeah then they're going to be voting
against that i start to wonder if a lot
of people think that
um the president is the one who got us
into this situation
then people are going to vote against
are going to vote democratic because of
that
you know it just starts to make me
wonder how like this
this thing that we're in right now is
gonna make people
vote because i don't even know if people
are voting for one person
anymore that much i mean i feel like as
much as they're voting against
how they want the world to be and what
they think
i think people used to vote for their
party right i think a lot of times
people voted for their party i think now
people are voting
because it's diverse now yeah i think
people hate the other person now
yeah yeah what you said i think people
used to vote oh i don't really love the
guy but i'm a republican so i vote for
xyz
now i think people go i [ __ ] hate
uh joe biden or i hate hillary or
whoever and they go off so i'm oh i'm
for sure going to vote for this guy
regardless of yeah the party they just
get so
they get so annoyed with with the other
party that they're like i'll do anything
to get rid to not to make sure they
don't get in
you know which in essence is the same
but i think it's more personal now
people
people really who hate trump hate trump
people who hate biden and hillary
and and and bernie same way they had the
same kind of hate on both sides so
but people have gotten so dive people
are more they're
we just have to get away from this
two-part two-party system is the most
flawed thing on earth yeah
and hopefully that's what i think is
that whatever is going on
over the past eight years four years and
in the future is
that's where it's leading us well you
should be able to pick you should be
able to pick from
you know what you have to have an odd
number isn't it wouldn't that be the
isn't that the case per so you'd have to
have like three per side or something
like that yeah
so yeah if it was three candidates from
the republican party three candidates
from the democratic party
that's who you would want to put up a
fight because then you'd get
an extreme from the republican a a
middle from the republican and then a
more
almost left-leaning republican or or
someone like
you know um pete buddha judge you know
who that you know yeah
judges almost like he could be both i
don't even he's somewhere in the middle
you know he's a gay vet who loves guns
but also is
is pro-gay marriage but also is very
conservative in his
financial approach about taxes so you're
like this guy's kind of all over the
place but you need that option
to be viable because it's legitimate
that's how people think these days
nobody is one way
at all no one's all the way in on
anything i don't believe it to be true i
wish we elected the president
and the vice president i always thought
that bernie and trump would have been a
good ticket
yeah like why does he get to bring his
friend to the party that we didn't
approve i don't understand that it's
always weird because yeah why did they
get to bring in
because then you could really check the
say if somebody got president then you
could check them
by having a uh a vice president
that had different views and like
totally incorporated more of your you
know
more of your views so then it would
always be like they're always going to
have somebody that they're going to have
to
discuss things with yeah you know yeah
no i think i think people are going to
this is going to change a lot but it
i'll change a lot but also i think
i think we need to get back to a place
where we step back
after all this chaos and we start to
understand that like agenda
isn't the way to get messages across we
need to have conversations yeah because
people are just hearing stuff and then
they get mad
like i got mad the other night not mad
but i just got i was like this is [ __ ]
there's a procter and gamble commercial
procter and gamble is a major [ __ ]
corporation
and it's a commercial where it's a young
it's a young black dad with his son
and they get looks everywhere they go
right there's a little girl waving out
of a mercedes a little white girl
and the mom rolls up the window when she
sees that she's waving at a black kid
and then he puts his son in the pool
and a and a white dad gets his son out
of the pool because the black guy
is in the pool and then the very end of
the commercial you see that he's
actually
they were in a courtroom and then you
pan around and he's a judge
the the the dad the black dad and it's
this
thing that's like it's a conversation we
need to have about um
racial inequality and judgment and
silent racist
uh intentions and yada yada
while i know what they're saying i know
what they're trying to communicate
i think that is so poorly done yeah this
is the commercial because all this does
to me is sh you could play it and play
in the background because i don't think
there's any it's just music there is no
uh
there's no dialogue but you know they
show him and his son having a good day
and then it's waving at a white girl
in a benz and the mom is like no way you
don't get to wave at blacks like
what what is this from 19 this is this
is now they're airing the [ __ ] right now
and look don't hold the elevator for the
black guy says the three whites in the
elevator
oh my god well i mean dude this is
insane this is going on i just saw this
last night when i was watching baseball
who was that a thot coming in the door
she's cute huh mm-hmm but look what
would you like to set the
table next to black eye no way we'd
rather sit over here
you know let's get out of the pool i
don't want to get in the pool because
the black guy's in there with his son
right oh you're in a fancy shoe store
look at the black guy look at the black
guy checked on the black guy he's black
we don't know what he's going to do in
here
so right the message is extremely
obvious of what procter gamble is saying
i just want to see what the script is at
the end
uh you know should i skip ahead yeah
he's a judge now you know we cut to a
courtroom they turn the cameras around
and
obviously we see he's a judge um
and their statement is for him man yeah
and this based on a true story
yeah yeah but it turns out he didn't
even go to school to be a judge
let's all talk ab let's all let's all
what is that let's all talk about the
look so we can
talk about the look so we can see beyond
it okay so here's my here's what here's
what i want to say about this and then i
don't want to ramble on two more about
it but
it made me mad last night because
i know what they're saying do do many
black people in america
or the maybe all maybe a high majority
feel
that they get that they get things like
this that things like this happen to
them
perhaps yes perhaps so that is that can
be true right yes
this message though is almost like
saying
all white people do this stuff yeah all
of you do this
which is so [ __ ] wrong and not true
that
this should say there's a very small
percentage of white people who
publicly have no shame in being racist
right and they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
and [ __ ] them forever yeah but but the
conversation that should it should say
let's talk about how people are
blatantly racist
and why it's wrong versus this shows
different factions of white people at
different levels of life
shunning black people and it's almost
saying
this is what you do without knowing it
it's like no the [ __ ] i don't right
no the [ __ ] i don't put that saying like
it's a this
i believe in my heart that most the high
majority of whites in this country
aren't inherently racist towards black
people in that fashion i agree right i
just don't believe that to be true and
i've agreed it for a long time
do i think there's some people that are
yes right yes
there are probably a portion of people
that see a black guy in a pool
and don't swim in it because that that
white guy's racist okay
do i think most do that no yeah but this
message is like saying
most if not all white people are racist
towards black people and i
just don't believe it i i just don't
think that's true
because it is perpetuating a narrative
that is
that is so broad how could you encompass
all those ignorant to have this be the
narrative almost
yeah it's [ __ ] up because that's not
how i [ __ ] feel so you're speaking
for me now
right proctor and [ __ ] gamble yeah
and so the
and a lot of this comes from i think the
people who make these commercials now
and who are in the driver's seat of a
lot of the advertising and all that
they're all from a lot of the same
places yeah it's the same repeat people
over and over again who have never lived
in different communities right
and so they think that this is what it's
like everywhere because that's what they
see
they don't live in those worlds you said
exactly what i said on
uh this last podcast i did with
fitzsimmons my biggest beef
with a lot of white people yelling the
loudest is they don't interact with
anybody of color
anyway right they have no black friends
they have no
[ __ ] saying just black friends they have
no friends of any other race besides
whites
so then they go this is what i think
other whites do right
well that you don't live in the world
especially procter and [ __ ] gamble
a trouble a massive corporation yeah
what world do you live in that you know
that and what i would rather see what i
think it would be more helpful
yeah would be to sow a commercial that
shows people of all ethnicities
treating a different ethnicity a certain
way
yeah because i think there's i believe
that there's way more bigotry
in the country than there is actual
inherent or
you know like that systemic racism
people talk about yeah i think there's
way more bigotry that goes all types of
ways
oh please like everyone is racist there
is so much bigotry to
any other race yeah it's not just a a
street of of
one-way street of white people being
racist to black people are so tired
white people who have been doing their
best their entire lives to not be racist
and to be supportive of black community
to be supportive of black artists
my my favorite comedians are black
and have been my whole life well the
most popular ones are yeah
like the best and they're the most
popular the most popular musicians like
i feel like there's a lot of like
support of black culture
i see that a lot more than i see stuff
like this anymore correct
um because this exists i'm not saying it
doesn't but it's so
small and you're making the rest of us
who aren't that way
you're making us angry not at black
people but you're making us angry at
this repeated
beating us over the head yes with the
narrative that doesn't apply to us
that you keep putting us into and i
think you're gonna have a lot of people
that are gonna vote in uh in the
election
against the media yeah and i don't know
what that vote looks like for them but i
think a lot of
people don't care who the candidates are
but if they can find a way to
vote against [ __ ] like this that's what
they want you said it right bro
they're beating you in the head with a
narrative that doesn't apply to you and
so it
infuriates people like me to go you're
saying that
you're it's like you're saying i need to
have this conversation
about racists i already know there's
racist pieces of [ __ ] yeah i don't need
[ __ ] them the conversation used to have
look how many people in our communities
at least the ones that i live in or my
friendship circle people that i'm a part
of
that are supportive of other cultures
and races and we get along and we enjoy
one another's company
if you put that image out more don't you
think that does better don't you think
it does better to show us interacting
with other cultures and races versus
going
this happens all the time this is
happening on a daily basis no
i have enough black friends that have
told me they get treated differently in
different situations
yeah i they have to my face been like no
when i walk into this kind of place
i get treated like this that's right it
happens right
but this is once again that is a small
amount of people
who are outwardly racist and do racist
things right
i'm not talking about subconscious races
i'm not talking about when you
when you when someone says they see a
black guy in a nice car and they go oh
he must be a rapper or an athlete
you know in their mind they go he can't
just be a lawyer right that's
subconscious racism that people have
i'm talking about this is blatant
obvious get my kid out of the pool
there's a black guy in the pool
this i just don't believe that this is
rampant i just and maybe it is in
certain parts of the world but
our country but i got to tell you that
ain't the [ __ ] majority no it's not
at all dude i was in oklahoma we were
touring we stopped in oklahoma at a lake
right this is one small little bitty
example we stopped in a place
yeah where if you showed pictures of the
place to
anybody in one of the coastal cities
they'd be like oh man you know i bet
there's
you know i bet there racism everywhere
right we went out and stopped and went
swimming in the side of this lake right
and it was mostly white people they had
three black kids there
or two black children that seemed full
black fully african-american and then
one black kid that seemed black and
white it was mexican and they were
part of the they had a black and white
couple and then they had a
one of the kids had been adopted and it
was like
they nobody there was doing there was no
race everybody's
having a good time like that's so much
more of what i've seen in my life
same i see more of that than i see the
other side and we travel the country
when somebody goes
you're a california liberal you don't
[ __ ] know what do you mean i lived on
planes for 10 years
going to every part of this country
seeing all different cultures
and yeah there are people that are that
have hate in their heart they exist
but you can't help that as much as you
can't help anything else it's like
that's going to ignorance will exist but
i think the message we need to show
people
is people getting along with other
people we need positivity in this shitty
time
show people interacting with people of
other procter gamble put out a
commercial
about how we're doing our best to be one
to be a race of humans
instead of this [ __ ] great divide you
know instead of
you know because it's not even real bro
that's the thing i know the divide is
not even real
no they've made it they've made it more
of a thing yeah the news wins when you
do that that's the scary thing well look
at what they did in portland you know
this is it's a [ __ ] war in portland
and you know look up the [ __ ] stats
of portland i just looked it up the
other day you know it's like it's not
even that bad
but but it's also like these storming
the streets for
for for black lives matter i understand
why people are protesting but you look
up portland oregon
on [ __ ] wikipedia and you're like the
inherent
[ __ ] racist past of portland oregon
you want to talk about go google it
of railroad workers that were black that
were basically socially enslaved in this
[ __ ] city
for years and it's and it's one of the
highest percentages of all white
communities in the united states
there's all these [ __ ] loud angry
white people with no black friends with
no black communities near
them but they're mad at things they have
no connection to and you're like
how real can it be when you've never
lived with any
other race do you really know what
you're talking about that's the thing
i've always said that
like how do you know you don't [ __ ]
live him it's like 79
[ __ ] white or something insane you're
like what
little i just like you're the most
segregated [ __ ] city in the united
states you're the most mad i don't
understand
like i don't get it that kind of stuff
blows my [ __ ] brain
that's crazy man i i just i just i get
frustrated because i'm like
yeah no he's frustrated we should be
coming together as
one dude and we should because that's
what we're actually doing in real life
we
are coming together yeah bro you watch
sport like
we are in reality we are coming together
you look at younger generation
all their friend groups i feel like a
lot of their friend groups are really
mixed
same i see that all the time all the
time but why isn't that on procter and
[ __ ] gamble
i don't know that's what my point is
like we need to push that narrative more
for us to be like yo
we're trying to get we're trying as a
community to grow and most people do i
think yeah andrew i think a lot of
people choose we can choose to and i
there are moments in the week
where i choose to want to get angry yeah
and so i go to find those things to
totally
make me that way but we need to not
anymore i think and we're trying and we
can do better
yeah that's what we can do better yeah
is not imbibe in their [ __ ]
right it's just pushing to the side yeah
if i want to be racist i'll be racing as
damn brendan he's [ __ ] half british i
found out yesterday is he really yeah
and you know you can't trust those
i mean you can trust him no you
documented that it's risky it's very
risky
it has a bad history he's half british
dude his aunt has an accent
oh [ __ ] really yeah
good day bro yeah ugh chip chip peerio
yeah clean out the gemini pub
that's his aunt dude she's putting a
thicky thick up on the roof right with a
damn
you know feather deal dude i got to come
on uh with you yeah you got to come on
you got to come on i want to have you on
so we can sit and talk and
yeah i want to come on a couple of
people shop yeah do they have
non-alcoholic whiskey i wonder
if not they have uh they have
de-alkalized
wine they have like soju that's
de-alkalized i don't know i'm gonna i'm
gonna find some i'll find some whiskey
that's do alkalize
let's try something huh yeah they gotta
have something that's close to it i'll
call free whiskey there you go they
gotta have something can we order let's
order one right now if you can if we can
nick yeah yeah yeah and then i'll bring
it in
that's great it's probably ritual zero
proof it is
and that's manhattan and i'll make you
an old fashioned or something oh yeah
yeah we'll make something good get a
bottle dude i'll come in yeah i want to
come in i'll come in a couple weeks i
think it'll be really fun
and we won't yell about what's going on
in the news as much it's just my passion
got real
it's okay man well it's just last night
rubbed me the wrong way
and then you know what's so funny i i
took my pictures and i just made me it
made me feel okay again you took that
dog
out i took my dog out and i was like
okay it's fine i was mad for a little
bit and then i was like
that's fine life is okay
right animals will show you that life is
fine like it's just
right they just show you that they're
like no it's [ __ ]
we're gonna be okay we just keep
functioning the way that we function you
don't need to worry about other people's
[ __ ]
like just it's really true man it's like
yeah we just have it's always
that it's just like do what you can do
yeah do what you can do
try your best we're all gonna die so
have some fun figure it out be as cool
as you can
yeah be a part of yeah try yeah just try
to be a part of
something that's a little different you
know sometimes it's tough you know yeah
sometimes you grow up with stereotypes
dude like i grew up yeah we
didn't have any wealthy black people
when i was growing up except for some
athletes
right so then i would get older and when
i would see a black eye in a nice car
i would think oh is that guy at us for a
certain age i would think
oh that guy must be an art a musician or
an athlete
right because you never saw anything
else it was the only thing that was the
only way black
people could get ahead but now
in places you see a black eye it's not
you don't think the same thing
no well if you live in an area that has
thriving culture yeah yeah it helps to
live in a place where you go
a major metropolitan area when you see
people have millions of different
careers and there's not just one way to
get out of a
either impoverished or lower
socioeconomic place right you when you
see it
you learn it you grow yeah the more you
[ __ ] travel
the more you meet more people and i
don't mean travel to like i'm
vacationing in france i mean
go two states over yeah go see how other
people live in different places you
automatically learn
inherently that your view of culture is
not the it's your
little telescope is all you see in your
hometown when you leave that and you go
to other places you go
[ __ ] they don't function like that they
don't feel this way it's worse
that's one thing that's great i think
about the whole black lives matter
movement is it duh
it has made me examine how do i
look at other races and cultures like
just to make sure like check in and be
like do you have a different do you have
like preconceived notions when you see a
black guy sure
like just from your own stereotype or
stereotypes over the years or your own
experiences
do you have preconceived notions about
anybody i think there's been some i
noticed a little bit where i'm like
i'm a little bit more pensive sometimes
when i see black people i have a fear
just from my own experiences growing up
right you know growing up like uh but i
don't think that's racist as much as
that is just
your your your childhood right agreed i
agree
right but also it's good like some of
this movement has made me stop and look
and say hey man
be you can do you can try to be
to not carry those sometimes totally you
can try to
because people can feel that energy and
i don't have i mean i have black friends
you know i have
like i don't always have it but there's
moments
where it's like hey man you know
recognize that you're just kind of
having maybe a little bit of that flare
up or a little bit of stereotype and see
if you could just not
you know try to let it be you know well
yeah because you know that
so that's one thing that's great about
this i do think is that it does
it helps people be introspective yes
yeah you should look inside yourself
and i think that's a positive thing
because you know that any flaw you have
doesn't come from hate
yeah right that's the difference that's
why i'm asking people to let people grow
yeah it's like i'm sure it doesn't come
from hate i'm sure it comes from
ignorance or
or or or or misinformation or a lack of
or a lack of interaction that's okay
let's let people grow though and yeah
because otherwise we're
we're [ __ ] we're all gonna be canceled
what's that zero
oh you bought it oh i like it hey man i
like it we can't put yeah that's i like
that well
can we get some zero-proof coke nick
will you order that as well dude we can
get some b12 actually and do that
let's let's do some b12 that's what you
do on tv when you sniff yeah
i've done it before dude i did something
i hit some uh a pilot like a year and a
half ago
and they had it there's like these two
like 15 year old girls doing it at this
pool
and i went over there and did about
eight lines this is the good old days oh
yeah bro i've been
yeah pissed like a [ __ ] straight up
wizard dude like a water wizard the rest
of that day
the b12 does uh it does kind of give you
a little tickle though oh like it
doesn't make it wake you up a little bit
it's a little baby bump yeah it's like
uh whoa whoa whoa what up
okay it's only it's only a couple
seconds but then
yeah we'll have you on we'll drink some
some zero proof i'm in yeah the world
the world will be it will be a better
place too it will man uh
check android on bad friends and whiskey
ginger thanks so much
thank you dude i appreciate it thank you
bro now i'm just floating
on the breeze and i feel like
[Music]
it in my bones
but it's gonna take a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these wells that i've been robbing
on they want so
they just